ils se sont réunis dès 3 heures 15 ce
matin à l'ouverture des grilles de cet
entrepôt de bonnes
ils sont transporteurs chauffeurs ou
employé de magasin
ils refusent de travailler les jours
fériés une demande récente de leur
direction basée sur le volontariat sans
vantardise et parce qu'on nous impose
quatre jours les jours fériés sous
l'année sachant qu'on a un jour sur la
solidarité vous pour les anciens ils
trois jours qu'on nous impose
on nous dit que c'est le volontaire mais
on nous impose même trois jours à
choisir pour moi c'est pas du
volontariat les magasins aldi ouvre
désormais six jours fériés par an un
changement nécessaire pour répondre aux
exigences du marché et de la clientèle
selon la direction du travail
supplémentaire mal rétribué selon les
employés on demande à tirer sur les
horaires faire plus de travail faire
plus de chiffre de profits puis on va
vous proposer hui vous serez payé un
jour férié à 125% les années passées
c'était ses dettes ou module est chez
nous donc en fait pour les plus petits
salaires
ça se voyait pas sur la paye en fin du
mois ils ne sont pas en colère mais leur
moral est atteint
en ce lundi de pentecôte ils ne sont
d'ailleurs qu'une petite vingtaine à se
mobiliser beaucoup n'ose mettre là parce
que le souci c'est que dans les magasins
on est des potiers deux équipes
donc c'est pas toujours évident quand il
ya une personne ou deux qui veulent
faire la grève suivre parce que souvent
elles ont peur des retombées la
direction d'aldi n'a pas souhaité nous
répondre face caméra par écrit il
précise qu'une réunion est fixée avec
les délégués syndicaux le 24 mai
prochain